Secretary of Defense James Mad Dog
Madison with US troops at the southern
border today as a breakaway group of a
few hundred migrants from the caravan
reaches Tijuana and is seen climbing the
border fence secretary Madison he's
confident about securing the border as
the caravan arrives I'm 100% confident
we have the number of troops at each of
those ports of entry to complete the
what we've been asked to do prior to the
arrival of the large Caravan
wherever they choose we go right now
mattis's trip comes amid reports that
President Trump is considering replacing
homeland security secretary
Kirsten Nielsen Trump telling the Daily
Caller a decision could be coming
shortly meanwhile the big question on
Capitol Hill is will Republicans finally
be able to get funding for the border
wall passed Congressman Jim Jordan
urging fellow lawmakers to make it their
highest priority single biggest promise
we made the American people in 2016 that
we have not got done yet building the
border security wall in securing the
border we should be focused on that one
main thing over the next several weeks
as we still have a few few weeks left
while Republicans control all of
government we should focus on the
biggest promise we made them and what
they sent us here to do and former
acting ice director Thomas home and his
warning Democrats will try to target
Isis budget when they officially take
over the house I think they're going
look to cut the ice budget which means
they'll fund less beds which equals less
arrests and less deportations and more
catch and release I certainly I
certainly think it's going to be a
struggle with the house under Democratic
control because they don't want
immigration enforcement alright so let's
take a look at the caravan or I guess
some stragglers beat everybody to the
punch and it's there the fast ones for
aldo yeah they made it to Tijuana and
how easy is it to climb that wall
they're sitting up on top of the wall
straddling it they fall then they scurry
back when they see any sort of presence
on the other side it's kind of a joke
isn't it well I think a new wall would
be kind of a joke also a 30-foot high
multi-billion dollar wall can be easily
defeated by a $25 31 foot ladder what I
am relieved is that the demonization of
this group of people are you the
electrode o-type doesn't prevent against
ladders I think they took that into
consideration her old walls walls stop
Juan and Maria the ordinary fruit picker
the babysitter the lawnmower
they don't stop ms-13 in the gangbangers
they tunnel under it they fly over it
they they boat around at a wall doesn't
stop the professional criminals but it
is so firmly ingrained in the American
psyche now that I have withdrawn my
objection to the wall if you want to
spend
five billion dollars to build a wall
haven't you mean Mexico's gonna pay for
it hold your that's breaking news from
Geraldo what do you think Greg I think I
think this is it's a sad story because
this was a politically motivated
phenomenon which which paints a group of
people as cheating line cutting taking
advantage of being murderer yeah and
it's not and the fact is it was
politically motivated by activists and
and they claim that they're fleeing
danger for safety but they're fleeing
right through in past Mexico which is
offering them refuge it's like driving
to the second hospital you see when
you're shot not the first one it doesn't
make any sense so that that's a
contradiction but the problem here is
that Americans are good people we like
immigrants we are immigrants but this
politically motivated phenomenon
triggered our sense of unfairness and
line cutting so you see people get upset
about it because they feel that America
is being taken advantage of if we just
and by the way the reason why they're
getting there faster is there but there
are buses now so there's all these
questions that nobody answered for
example who how did this start who
started it how are these people being
fed and clothed and where are the
bathrooms and then how can they trout go
so far so quickly and we're seeing that
that they're using transportation so we
see that this is all an artificially
created phenomenon and everybody comes
out looking the worst and now there's
going to be a big battle in the House
Kennedy how are they going to in the
lame duck fund the wall at all I heard
five million is on the table from
senator Mitch McConnell a million that's
five billion excuse me and they're
talking about defunding possibly when
Pelosi takes over the gavel of ice yes
the Democrats have talked about that
it's really the progressive wing of the
Democrat Party because mainstream
Democrats populist Democrats from the
Midwest they really don't have a lot of
interest in that because they don't have
an answer for what do you do in place of
ice and that's the problem that
Republicans ran into replacing Obamacare
they really didn't have a great solution
for that and people are going to get
very sick and tired of that brand of
obstructionism Republicans really
couldn't
do much when they had the majority in
both chambers so how on earth are you
going to create the sense of urgency
just because you have a compressed
timeline and the interesting thing here
is you really do have a solution
Democrats have something they want
Republicans who support the president
have something they want and if you
trade dreamers for the wall it's both
sides really are not far off in this
column it's too sensible that was the
problem is both sides love it you're
absolutely right about the activists on
both sides they love the entrenchment
it's one of those issues where everyone
wins when a group doping is the middle
there was a deal on the table and then
for some reason it fell apart Morgan now
they're also talking about getting rid
of Kirsten Nielsen Trump allegedly if
you're gonna believe the media right now
is very upset with her she's not doing
enough on the border and he's thinking
about replacing her as soon as tomorrow
we're hearing well I just want to say
for the record I'm super happy that
we're still talking about the caravan
but listen when it comes to well they
said that the Fox was going to stop so
everybody in the cabinet serves at the
pleasure of the president right so if
the president wants to remove someone
because he doesn't feel that person's
doing a good job whether it's her or not
that's his prerogative as
commander-in-chief to do as he wants
what I think was really important
actually is that mattis went down there
and all of you know that I'm you know a
national security person and I think by
Madison down there he really signaled
that this is this is a legitimate
mission this is a national security you
don't do stunts did he said that he's
supportive but he also talked about this
sort of being a moral issue he framed
what happened a hundred years ago
whenever the military went down to the
southwest border to protect it so
although a lot of people may not like
the president's rhetoric or may make fun
of him talking about the wall I think
what's important to note is that his
strong action on this and his strong
words on that I think are really
preventing people from getting from from
getting even closer but the most
important thing I think is what Geraldo
said that the true people that we have
to look at from a national security
perspective or not that are not the
economic migrants or the refugees the
real problem of the gangs in the ms-13
and that's why you need the military and
that's why you need to beef up ice and
that's why
maddis is down there because this is
about national security it's not about a
few poor migrants training her although
you I want you to respond to what
Kennedy said do you think that the
Republicans may have lost some seats in
the house because they had the
majorities and they didn't pay for the
wall I don't think that's what happened
I think the president and the nation
suffered the double misfortune the
tragedy of the massacre and the Jewish
synagogue in Pittsburgh and the bomber
sending bombs out the week before the
election giving America a sense of
disquiet
and looking at President Trump as being
less than invulnerable you know he
seemed shattered or rattled let me the
better word 2020 two years from now
there's still no border wall funding and
there's still caravans coming that's
gonna hurt turnout among Republicans I
have urged the President to his face and
conversations to please take the Kennedy
deal give the dreamers a pathway to
citizenship the Democrats have already
said they will fund the wall make them
stand up make them do that the elections
have consequences he's earned his wall
just as the dreamers have earned their
path to citizenship but I have to say
you referenced something that secretary
mattis said about a hundred years ago
150 years ago Arizona New Mexico
Colorado California and all these other
states belonged to Mexico so there is a
special relationship that has to be
recognized we have 7 million unfilled
jobs in this country we have fruit and
vegetables dying on the vine I think we
have to get off the dime we have to
force our political leaders right and
left
red blue Republican and a Democrat to
fix this problem enough already hit
enough grandstand all right I get it
it's important that we have people to go
do these jobs so that the one thing that
drives me crazy about this is that
whenever you are for the law and order
process whether it is for prisons strong
borders or terror
that's opposing side is always going to
say that you're against a certain group
of people you're always going to be
painted as mean so if you have a strong
border you're you don't like brown
people if you're if you are Pro if
you're you want strong strong on terror
you're Islamophobic
if you're a strong criminal justice
system you just want to incarcerate more
blacks which I've actually prints and
Trump show today is not but the point is
if you are a law-and-order person the
only argument that you're gonna get in
response is that you're just a mean
bigot and I think that really diminishes
the debate it does because they can't
argue on substance they have to smear